in keeping with what you set out for may
not be what you end up with what happens
when you'd said earlier if the dream
becomes a nightmare you tell us that
it's reality dreams are not reality if I
don't know about you but every now and
then I have a dream at night this is
fantasy world and it's a culmination of
different things happened every day I
think when it comes to celebrity or
being famous talk show host famous actor
you have your idea in your mind what
it's going to be like if you were to
ever accomplish it and I think what
happens is once you accomplish it
everything has an equal opposite side to
it you know take the internet for
example we all love the internet
convenient fast information readily
available well there's also crazy child
predators on there that are looking to
do horrible evil things is he is the
internet evil know it's a flip side same
thing with Fame you know you can be a
celebrity you get this money you get the
saturation great about yourself well
yeah you also live in a bubble things
that you took for granted you can't do
anymore you can't just get up and go to
Starbucks you can have the paparazzi
chasing you look what happen to Lady
Diana I'll give you a closer example my
boss Glenn Beck he came out with a
children's book around Christmastime it
was a year ago and he had an interview
with Kathie Lee Gifford and he was
talking about his childhood and breaking
the chains of alcoholism in the family
and she asked him because he did a lot
of people know that some people really
hate him was his intention to be hated
but there's the flip side of his success
is that there are people who disagree
with them disagree with his conclusions
but they don't just disagree they hate
him I mean a vile hatred that is hard to
kind of wrap your brain around and so he
can't just walk around New York City
like a regular person
yes at the security detail not some fat
dude who's just clearing the crowd I
mean a legitimate trained professionals
because of the threats now that's got to
take its toll and Kathie Lee asked him
isn't worth it was it all worth it he
gave a very interesting answer an honest
one he said I don't know because he's
seen the impact its had on not only
himself but more importantly is why is
children and that's something I think a
lot of people don't take any
consideration and in my case with radio
so I work all this time behind the
scenes I finally get an opportunity to
do with shells and does pain that's fine
because at first you're excited by the
opportunity and then it's like you're
feeding the monster it's a bottomless
pit you put more into it but nothing
changes and unless you have support
behind you whether or not it's you hit
critical mass with an audience and then
the company can't ignore you because
they see too much income potential
unless that scenario happens and it
organically just grows and blows up your
left in a situation where you need
somebody to take a gamble on you need
somebody to help you out and in my
particular case at a program director
who mean I don't think very much of them
he's not very good to people and he
wasn't very helpful and I got into the
situation where I'm doing a show and
there was no support you know and and
the attitude was hopes we're letting you
do this show I'm feeling time for you
you know I think we're you know I'm
doing my part I'm putting on a great
show you're providing opportunity I
think this potential here a lot of other
people do but he disagreed with my
opinions
and so you just kind of let it ride and
then what happens is you start realizing
you're putting it all this time putting
it all this effort and you're going over
and I think that applies to people who
have the dream of being an actor or
anything else that when you finally get
there you realize that so often is not
what you thought it was and so that's
the reality because every job I don't
care what it is no matter how good it
looks on the outside this always flips
up there's always a downside to every
job and so I think that's something that
comes as a shock to some people I think
they think if they just arrived at that
location whoa it's perfect it's just not
real life
you